hi my name is Aaron and my question is
what what was your favorite from any of
the season and any character who said it
I'll hop on that real quick when I when
I read the pilot I saw myself in this
end of scene with Supergirl saying up in
the way I'm like I don't remember anyone
else's line but I remember some of mine
my favorite line was start the car I'm
just a girl trying to make a name for
herself outside her family my pretty
silly
[Music]
Kyler has this line in season one and
can't remember which episode but he has
the Sun gun but turns other licenses are
over powers back and she said here comes
Tyler I could not keep it together every
time does anyone else have a mic
lifesavers was the reveal in episode 7
season one where you say I am the sole
survivor one planet last son of Mars my
name is Jean Jones I love that tech
Donovan great like different girl of
Supergirl
[Applause]
are badass
right hi it's what I'm talking about
with Mon L also being super girl by the
way
this is what's to come are you collected
Supergirl twist your question so my
question is obviously Karan has had a
lot of interest in each season so with
mono gone does that mean the car gets to
explore herself per season with no love
interest I mean from what I've seen so
far
she really is you know trusting herself
and only herself right now
and obviously relying on her friends but
she's she's been pretty self-reliant so
far recent tonight piggybacking off of
that she worked so hard and season two
to really hone her reporting skills and
to prove herself are we even see her
containment at Catco yeah yes
I mean her relationship with taco is
always kind of up and down and in flux
so I think we'll continue seeing that
but she would be who she is without
being a reporter
well Jamie what's your question hi my
name is Taylor wearing the costumes or
the speeches of the last two days have
been amazed how do you feel I feel so
badass
whoa a little girls running up to me
wanting to significant imagine what it's
like wearing Lee Hopsin for a living and
I wanted to ask you knowing what you do
now
what advice would you give your
character for the coming season that's
tough I mean I can't I can't see all the
way down into what happened hey Clark
[Laughter]
but I think I'd tell her because of what
she's been through so far that her
optimism has always and her hope and
compassion have always got her through
so she should forget that and I always
listen to everything Kat Graham says
this is gonna be our last band question
what's your name what's your coach if
you would call them hi my name is Julia
Jenkins and my Superman hi I'm John Hale
hi John um we were wondering that we
love the team-up of Superman and
Supergirl because obviously that they're
cousins and they need to be together
but we were wondering if we're going to
see any more of Superman as a sidekick
in the coming season
we love having Superman on the show and
we hope there are no immediate episodes
with Superman but we are we are hoping
that schedule permitting and storyline
permitting that we will see him again
with will Joker all right guys we've got
time for one more question I'm going to
open it up to everyone and it is your
opportunity to kind of pitch something
right now to your show runners we're
going to go with down the line starting
with Katie what is one thing you really
like to see your character accomplish
this season I want to find out about my
real mother I want to know that I want
to open that box because you know maybe
maybe she's made him maybe I have
superpowers maybe I will be the only one
that doesn't have a costume
they protect me from John I would like
to see Jean Jones get wildly drunk being
a karaoke song in the give me in the
alien Guide bar supergirl the other
puppies here at the base puppy we've
been talking about for three years I
went up happy I don't think about me but
course oh no I feel that that win has a
sort of depth to him that we have really
explored a lot and he covers up a lot of
stuff and kind of sweeps it under the
rug and it is always kind of laughing
off and making jokes but I feel like
that a lot of the time that is to kind
of cover you know dogs that are buried
underneath you know we've seen with his
father that you know he has the Scimitar
hand man humans demons so I would have
up to maybe get a handle on those a
little bit more look hi what would you
like to see some drink
I would love to I'd love to know how
Superman feels about his best friend
being Guardian oh that was like even
rain well I keep hearing that rain will
be a real match for Supergirl so I
clearly want to see an epic showdown
prepared and last but not least Chris
but that him driving yeah don't get in
pods anymore that's my advice where he
stopped I want to see that yet it's not
that pod it's a bad pod beginning I want
to see I want to see you know with
friends the one with Joey Ross I want to
see an episode where win and mono
accidentally take a nap together
I think there's some story that we
should explore it writers I think we
need you in the writers room I think you
all
you